kanye west continues to trash pete
davidson as the saturday night live star
rejoins instagram
i'm just extremely happy can you tell by
my face
on thursday just days after the grammy
winner wiped his account clean he was
back on the gram taking aim at his
estranged wife kim kardashian's nubo
with two posts the first this screenshot
of the 28 year old comedian on snl
wearing a make kanye 2006 again hat yay
asks in the caption quote hi skeet you
got any more mental health jokes for me
the rapper also posted this clip from
the same 2018 sketch where pete weighed
in on kanye giving an impromptu pro
donald trump speech to the saturday
night live audience after his
performance on the show a week earlier
kanye i know you're like yo this is the
real me i'm off the meds
take him
there's no shame in the in the medicine
game i'm on him great
take him there's nothing wrong with take
him if i ever got on a plane and the
pilot said i just want all you to know
this is the real me flying
i jump out
being mentally ill is not an excuse to
act like a jackass
kanye captioned the clip in part quote
this is not harassment this is payback
but in true kanye fashion he deleted all
the posts after only a few hours so is
there anything kanye can do to win you
back yeah there is and i'll tell you in
a way that kanye understands i made this
make kanye 2006 again of course the 44
year old rapper's posts come after pete
rejoined to the platform following a
long social media hiatus
you know social media is such a great
tool but of course you need boundaries i
think everyone does and get this he's
only following two people sebastian stan
and kim
i love that and while the king of staten
island star hasn't posted anything yet
he racked up over 1 million followers in
less than a day
including the 41 year old kkw beauty
founder
yup meanwhile kim has officially
unfollowed kanye but for now kanye is
still following kim i'm just rolling
with it and it is what it is
of course the two have been at odds
publicly feuding on social media amid
their ongoing divorce still the stronger
rapper seems determined to win the
mother of his four kids back a source
previously told et quote kanye is still
obsessed with getting his family back
together it's a sentiment he expressed
live on stage in december when he
changed the lyrics to his hit run away
[Music]
as for pete our source says he is super
chill about the situation and doesn't
take it too personally alluding to the
numerous posts from kanye aimed at him
quote he hates that kim has to deal with
the drama pete is certainly helping her
through this and has been supportive and
reminding her not to focus on it too
much i love that energy in my life the
lovebirds started dating after kim's
hosting gig on saturday night live back
in october
i mean i like you just the way you are
now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
and the two were spotted on valentine's
day weekend heading out for multiple
dinner dates pete even extended the love
to kim's famous fam sending her sister
chloe flowers for the special day
i love that so how serious are kim and
pete a source previously told e.t things
are really good between them adding he
makes her laugh plays around and has a
sense of humor it is nice for kim to be
around that
[Music]
you